Kevin Feige, who has served as the president
of Marvel Studios since before the MCU was
even a thing, finally broke his silence about
the future of Marvel fans' favorite armored
hero.
Recently, he shed just the teensiest bit of
light on who might replace Iron Man in the
MCU, who notably sacrificed his life for the
safety of the entire universe in Avengers:
Endgame.
Turns out we won't be seeing a replacement
for quite some time.
Past reports have focused on the Marvel Comics
character Ironheart: a girl named Riri Williams
who builds her own superhero suit based on
Iron Man's armor and even gets his stamp of
approval to be a vigilante, would be the lucky
one to assume the Iron Man mantle in the wake
of Tony Stark's death.
After Iron Man falls into a coma following
a fight in a comic storyline, Riri protects
innocent civilians in his stead, looking out
for the world as Ironheart.
It makes sense that Ironheart might replace
Iron Man on the big screen given her personal
evolution in the comics, but Feige hinted
that it isn't a done deal in the slightest.
In an interview with BET ahead of the July
2 release of Spider-Man: Far From Home, Feige
got to talking about a replacement for Iron
Man when the interviewer, Jerry L. Barrow,
mentioned that Downey Jr. had said during
the Gene Siskel Film Center Gala in June that
Ironheart should join the MCU.
Feige shared that he adores the character
of Riri Williams, but admitted that nothing
is set in stone at this time.
Feige told Barrow:
Without using words, Feige essentially clarified
that he doesn't know what the future holds
for Ironheart and isn't at liberty to discuss
whether or not she can, will, or should be
a part of the MCU.
Later on in the interview, Feige mentioned
that he continues to be blown away by fans'
response to Marvel Comics characters, and
fully understands why there's a seemingly
never-ending list of heroes people want to
see debut in the MCU.
He owned up to initially finding the constant
questions about whether particular characters
would appear on the big screen to be frustrating,
then said that he now views it as a great
privilege to be able to make movies for such
a passionate fandom.
Fans have long thought Riri Williams would
eventually suit up as Ironheart and fly into
the MCU, and the desire to see that happen
has only burned stronger in the time since
Avengers: Endgame debuted in theaters in late
April.
The final moments of the film saw Iron Man
snap his fingers, turn Thanos and his alien
army to dust, and die knowing that his passing
meant a safe future for his family and his
fellow Avengers.
When another Avenger, Chris Evans' Captain
America, passed on his superhero mantle to
Anthony Mackie's Sam Wilson, many Marvelites
wondered how the MCU would fill the Iron Man-sized
gap and who would be the hero to replace him.
"I'll be Tony Stark."
"What?"
Sorry Brucie…the general consensus is that
Ironheart should be that vigilante - and it
isn't just fans who support the idea.
Robert Downey Jr. clearly does, and Spider-Man
actor Tom Holland does as well.
Previously asked about who he would like to
see join the MCU down the line, Holland answered,
quote:
Even still, Feige's comments to BET make sense.
It really is too early to say when and if
Ironheart will soar into the Marvel movie
universe, since the characters in the MCU
haven't yet begun to grieve the loss of Iron
Man...and because Marvel still hasn't announced
what's coming next in Phase 4.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.